>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mark Dimunation:
Welcome back to Rare Books
and Special Collections Division.
I'm Mark Dimunation.
I'm chief of the division here.
You're in for a real treat today.
We're very excited to have Valerie
Lester here who will be speaking
on her biography of Bodoni, the
first in the English language yes?
>> Valerie Lester: Yes.
Yes.
>> Mark Dimunation: Yes.
You will find some very
interesting things about Bodoni
who is the creator for
those of you who don't live
in my world of 18 century typeface.
Perhaps one of the most
elegant typefaces developed
but there's many interesting
parallels between Bodoni
and the biography and
the biographer.
Bodoni's font is among other
things noted for high contrasts
between thins and thicks and
thick and black and very narrow
and certain moments in reading this
type it creates what's called dazzle
which is a vibration that's caused
by the relationship between thin
and thick and Bodoni's life
itself is full as we have learned
in the biography of something
far more than you would imagine
of a typographer full of dazzle and
highs and lows and thicks and thins
and so you'll have the experience
of learning them and hearing
about that today from Valerie
Lester whose own experience
as a biographer parallels
this kind of experience
that Bodoni's type has created for
us which is a lot of dazzle coming
from Italian later in life yes,
in order to conduct this biography
and she also comes
from a perspective a little
outside our field which means
that it's opened up to receive
Bodoni as a full-fledged,
fleshed-out individual and not
merely a typographer but somebody
who lived life with
a good deal of gusto.
So we're very thrilled
to have her here.
This is an important book.
She's been on a book tour already
and this is already quite a
phenomenon but before she gets
up to speak I thought we can't have
such an elevated individual here
without at least telling
a few stories about her
so I've asked Stan Nelson
to actually introduce her
so Stan would you come on up?
>> Stan Nelson: This is impromptu.
I didn't plan on this.
Valerie contacted me with questions
about the process of punch cutting
and it became very evident
that it would be just best
to have her come visit me
so she journeyed to the wild
and wonderful West Virginia and
joined me in my studio for a couple
of days and we were cutting
punches and she got her hands dirty
and learned something really
real about this process
of shaping letters in steel
and I think as a result began
to understand just what an
incredible accomplishment
that Bodoni had achieved his
life with all of the vast variety
of typefaces that were produced.
And I of course, I had a
wonderful time working with Valerie
and I was pretty impressed with her
ability to absorb all this material.
She was carrying with her when she
arrived several wonderful books
in Italian and it was very
evident as we looked at those
that the problem has been that
this material was not available
in English.
The Italian's had produced wonderful
books about Bodoni but not books
that I could really appreciate
other than look at the pictures.
I understand better my grandchildren
looking at books and going oh
and not getting the text.
So you're going to have a
very enjoyable time hearing
about this project and
what she's accomplished.
It's a really remarkable
achievement.
>> Valerie Lester: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you Mark for having me here.
Thank you Stan for introducing
me and for your hospitality
and thank you all for coming.
This is great.
Bodoni, all right.
Born in Saluzzo in Piemonte
which is Northwest Italy in 1740.
He apprenticed in Rome and then he
spent his professional life in Parma
which is in north central Italy.
This is a town in which he was
born and it's absolutely gorgeous.
It's off the beaten path
and if you walk up any
of the narrow little streets
you'll see this massive mountain
which is called Monte Viso.
It's the highest mountain
in the Cottian Alps
and it has three sources
of the River Po.
They join together as they
come off the mountain.
They go through Saluzzo and
then the mighty Po makes its way
across the entire north of Italy and
eventually mouths into the Adriatic.
This is the house in which he
was born and any speak Italian?
Well, if you did you
would understand
that it is now a dry cleaners, a dry
cleaning and dying establishment.
The plaque on the wall here
tells you that his date
of birth is February the
26th not the 16th as recorded
by his principal Italian biographer.
So I think this is right.
Here's Bodoni's grandfather on the
left and his father on the right.
He came from a family
of printers even
on his mother's side
there was printing.
His grandfather before him went to
Rome to get training and his father,
I don't think his father actually
went to Rome, but try to remember
that style of printing on
the right his father's style
and you will see it again.
This is the schoolroom, well this is
the school in which Bodoni studied
in Saluzzo and I understand
that in the winter
when it was very cold they would
put waxed paper over the windows
in order to see and you
imagine it is pretty cold
up near Monte Viso in the winter.
When he was 17, nearly 18,
he and a good friend decided
that they would go and conquer Rome.
Bodoni wanted to become the
greatest printer who ever lived
and his friend wanted to become
the greatest servant of God
who ever lived so off they set
these two boys and made a journey
which was described as one of
the writers in Italian about him
as arduous and fatiguing to
Rome as indeed I'm sure it was
to get, to travel in those days.
So they arrived in Rome and found
it very difficult to find work
and it was really challenging
and in fact beyond
protopriest went back home
where he did become a parish
priest and they remained in touch.
Bodoni hung on and
eventually he found his way
to the College of the
Propaganda Fide.
The Propaganda Fide being the
missionary arm of the Vatican
and thus an establishment that
printed Bibles and Missals
in exotic languages in order to
convert people in the Middle East
and the Far East, so
already there was exotic type
at the Propaganda Fide
when Bodoni arrived.
He's so impressed Cardinal
Spinelli who was the head
of the Propaganda Fide with his
little wood engravings he took these
along as samples of what he
could do and the story goes
that Cardinal Spinelli gave
him a test, asked him to design
and cut a Coat of Arms in a
couple of hours or something.
Well Bodoni of course managed
and he was hired on the spot.
Spinelli also took him into
his own home which happened
to be the Palazzo Valentini which is
the building on the right side here.
So Bodoni just imagine he was
up in you know lowly apprentice,
you know up in one of those
sky lit rooms up top there.
So in the morning he could
roll out of bed and just walk
down into the Forum of Trajan and
finds himself face-to-face with some
of the most important
lettering every cut.
His first tasks, no
not his first task.
He started very low.
He did anything you know he
was kind if dog's body there
but he eventually started composing
and the first book he worked
on was what's called a
Pontificale, a book for Bishops
of services the Bishops would give
and this is actually quite
interesting and rare.
On the left you have the first run,
Bodoni's first run at doing this
and so it's printed in two colors.
It's printed in two
languages Coptic and Arabic.
The powers that be were so
impressed by what he could do
that they then went on to print
lots more copies and allowed him
to sign his name, no
to print his name.
It's not his signature, to
print his name at the bottom
which was very unusual
for a lowly typesetter
but they were so pleased about it.
Now the one on the left is actually
in the Houghton Library at Harvard
and it's quite a big book and it has
in pencil written in it "very rare."
So I was absolutely fascinated
because I went back to Parma
in February and presented the book
which was a wonderful moment for me
to go back to the city
where I'd worked so hard
with an actual product
which I'm not convinced
that they thought I was
capable of doing but I did.
So I showed this image
and they had never seen it
so it is indeed very
rare the one on the left.
Bodoni worked for six years in Rome
and then you know how
things come together
to make you make some
kind of move in life?
Cardinal Spinelli died and Bodoni's
immediate superior Abbe Ruggieri
killed himself, shot himself and
this was a terrible, terrible thing
for Bodoni because they
were very close and Bodoni,
Ruggieri was depressant and but
he found relief from depression
in the company of Bodoni.
Bodoni was very vibrant and so
Bodoni in the mornings would go
over to the, to Abbe Ruggieri's
home and he would wait for him
until he was ready and then
they would walk together
to the Propaganda Fide.
On this morning Bodoni went over.
The servant told him that Abbe was
not ready and then there was a sound
of the shot and he
had killed himself.
Now if you think about the
circumstances there how terrible
that must have been for
Bodoni and you wonder
about Ruggieri's motivation
in killing himself
at that very moment it's kind of
one of these unsolved mysteries
but it set Bodoni up for
wanting to leave Rome.
On the brighter side Bodoni had
met quite a few English tourists
in Rome, part of the grand tour they
were there also carting goods back
to England to museums and to their
stately homes in England from Italy
and then had told him that there
are things happening in England.
There's quite a lot of
innovation going on.
There's this chap called Baskerville
and Bodoni thought, yeah, I better.
I want to stretch my wings.
I will go to England.
Never mind that I didn't
speak English.
Everybody in England was speaking
Italian because they liked opera.
So off he went and he decided that
he would stop and see his parents
on the way in Saluzzo because
it's near directly north
and then he would go on to
England but on the way he fell ill.
And we think it was malaria and
he was quite ill so he went home
to his mother and she
took care of him
and when he recovered he started
working again with his father
in the family printworks.
Until the meantime in Parma the
young 18 year-old Duke of Parma
and his wonderfully attractive Prime
Minister Guillaume Du Tillot wanted
to put Parma on the map and how
did you do that in those days?
Well you did that by setting
up a printworks in your city
so that you could advertise
your city
as being quite the most marvelous
and charming place in Italy.
But how could they go about this?
How could they set out to
just start a printworks
and a press from nothing?
Well, Guillaume Du Tillot being
French consulted a great connoisseur
in Paris called Pierre-Jean
Mariette.
Pierre-Jean Mariette was a wise man
and he said do not hire a Frenchman.
Hire an Italian because you're going
to be printing a lot
of works in Italian.
If you want to get them
right hire Italian.
The problem was there were no
Italian's suitable for the job,
so there was a librarian, ha, ha,
ha in Parma Paulo Maria Paciaudi
who had known Bodoni in Rome
and coincidentally they
were both from Piedmont.
They were both Piedmontese and
they stick together Piedmontese
so he said, "I've met
this young man in Rome
and he is incredibly talented.
He is absolutely superb."
And by this time Bodoni
had cut some punches.
He had designed typer pages.
He had worked with exotic type.
In fact while he was in Rome he
was sent to La Sapienza University
of Rome where he studied
Hebrew and Arabic
and so he had working knowledge
of some exotic languages
and Paciaudi said, "I
think he would do."
So the Duke and the Prime
Minister sent off the invitation
and in February, 1768
Bodoni arrived in Parma.
They set up the printworks
and his apartment above.
That's called the Palazzo
della Pilotta
and it's an extraordinary building
built by the Farnese family
which includes the Farnese Theater
which is absolutely gigantic
and they could produce,
they could flood the floor
and produce naval battles in it.
It's quite an extraordinary place.
So Bodoni could print something
off, cross the bridge over the river
and arrive at the ducal palace to
show the Duke anything that you know
if he needed his approval.
Bodoni liked his food.
He had come from Rome
where the food is very kind
of vegetable-aised,
olive oil, very healthy.
Parma on the other hand,
you've heard of Parma ham?
You've heard of Parma cheese?
It's a very, very protein
driven diet mostly pork.
There's a lot of pork
and of course oh,
I meant to tell you that's
tortelli di erbette which is a sort
of ravioli-like pasta that contains
Swiss chard or wheat greens.
Do you know what we have here?
Can you tell what we
have here on the left?
>> Sausage maker.
>> Valerie Lester: Yes.
Yes, we do indeed have
the sausage maker.
So this is in the 11th
century baptistery so already
in Parma they were
devoted to their salami.
When Bodoni arrived he brought,
I think he brought a few punches
of his own but there was nothing.
There was nothing in Parma so
he had to order type from France
and his great hero in
printing was Fournier
and so he ordered Fournier type.
So in the beginning Bodoni is
Fournier and gradually as time went
on Fournier became Bodoni.
This I think you will
feel reminds you
of his father's work is still
old-fashioned his father's work.
So this is the very first thing
he actually printed in Parma
of substance and it is it's
essentially a poem of thanksgiving
for the recovery from once again,
malaria of Prime Minister Du Tillot.
The next big work was a presentation
volume for the marriage of the Duke
of Parma, 18 years old with
this Duchess of Austria,
one of the 16 children of
Maria Theresa of Austria.
At this point Maria
Theresa had a rather a lot
of marriageable daughters that
she needed to get out in the world
so she sent this one to Parma
to marry the Duke of Parma.
She sent Marie Antoinette to Paris
to marry the [inaudible] of France
and Carolina to Naples to
marry the king of Naples.
This one as you can probably
tell is a piece of work.
She very often she
Austrianized Parma.
She got rid of Guillaume Du Tillot
and it became a very different
place while she was there.
Anyway, to go back to this
fabulous presentation volume
that they produced in celebration of
the wedding Bodoni worked in concert
with Petitot who was an architect.
He had come to Parma to
brighten the face of Parma,
to build a few new buildings
and to kind of rehab others
and he was very gifted and he
and Bodoni worked hand and glove
on the book that you will see at the
bottom of this picture on the left.
Petitot was so pleased
with the finished volume
that he produced a funny little book
called "Masquerade a'la Grecque"
in which everybody in it is dressed
up in some sort of Greek outfit.
Anyway, there's the book again up
on the left on top of the column
and here's the title page.
Now you see the difference
between that
and the previous thing I showed you.
It's getting more Bodoni-like.
So within this volume, this great
big folio volume there are lots
of illustrations and there
are illustrations of battles
and uniforms and this is a Chinese
fair and this is an Arcadian theater
so the festivities went
on for weeks and one
of the performers was a local
soprano called affectionately La
Bastardella because ancestry was
a little suspect but she sang
in operas in celebration and
these were operas by Gluck
and take a very close
look at the next image.
You know what's going on here?
Bottom enhancement.
>> False bottom?
>> Valerie Lester:
Bottom enhancement.
The pot down on the bottom right
has the words Colla du Parma.
Colla is glue and the man doing the
enhancement is his name is Giusepe
du Colla.
A lot of play on words here
and he actually married,
he married Lucrezia Aguiari
to give her her full name.
And then at the end of the final
thing I've got is fireworks.
Bodoni was starting by now.
Fournier, gradually some of the
Fournier type was breaking down.
Bodoni was cutting his own to
replace it so the shift is going
on between Fournier and Bodoni.
Bodoni wanted to produce a specimen
book of ornaments so this page
of his hand drawing of
ornaments which is also
at the Houghton Library at
Harvard and he produced this.
This is a facsimile of
it and it's still very,
this is still very like Fournier.
Fournier has one of
these specimen books
that has a cover very like this.
And that's from the interior and
do any of you recognize this?
It's actually modern day ITC
Bodoni designed by Sumner Stone.
Some of you may know him and so
you can actually decorate your work
with this.
This is not Bodoni's
studio but his contemporary
so his printworks would have
looked very much like this.
People would have been
wearing the same things.
They would have been using
the same kind of equipment.
There are big windows that face out
towards the river so that's very,
very much like what he would have
the space he would have worked in.
Here is some of his punches and
the Bodoni Museum has them all,
huge collection, huge
collection of punches really,
really wonderful collection.
These are Bodoni's
matrices and molds.
This is not his press
but it's a facsimile.
He had six presses going at one
point, at one time and but none
of them remain but they managed
to get a facsimile of one of them.
This book is over on that table.
I'm very pleased that
we can see that book.
An Epithalamia is a book written
in celebration of a wedding
and the wedding was that of the
prince of Piedmont so we're back
in Piedmont royalty among
Piedmontese and the prince
of Piedmont married Marie
Clotilde, the Princess of France,
a princess of France so Bodoni
produced another marvelous
presentation volume and in what he
did in it was he had 26 pages each
with a different language, different
exotic type and the iconography
for the city that it
represented, the city in Piemonte
that it represented so this is the
page for Saluzzo for his hometown.
For some reason he chose to use
Armenian as the script and the image
above is of, it's actually got
rivers you know the tributaries
of the Po and various other
items of interest to Saluzzo.
That particular book made such an
impression on the Spanish ambassador
who lived in Rome but came to Parma
and was astounded by Bodoni's talent
and he felt very, very strongly that
Bodoni was wasting himself in Parma
when he should be actually in Rome.
He felt that Bodoni
was printing ephemera.
He was printing announcements,
invitations, playbills
and silly sonnets for would-be poets
who wanted their work
printed by the great Bodoni.
And he said, "If you come
to Rome I will give you your
own establishment.
You will publish the classics.
You will not have to do any
of this essentially grunt
work and so come to Rome.
Come to Rome."
Well Bodoni liked Parma.
He was comfortable in Parma.
However, in 1791 when the pressure
was really on from Azara to go
to Rome and Bodoni was
beginning to weaken and think
that you know it might be a good
idea the Duke heard about it
and he really didn't want to let
Bodoni go because Bodoni was,
well he was like a
rock star by this time.
He attracted people to Parma.
Tourists came to Parma
and they went first
to see Bodoni before they
paid tribute to the Duke.
He was, it's hard to imagine
nowadays but it was you know it was
like what's his name,
Steve Jobs, right?
Somebody like that,
star quality, big name.
So the Duke said, "No,
I can't let you go.
You must stay here but
here's what I'll do.
I'll give you your own private press
so you can print anything you want
as long as just stay here
and print what I want."
So that's the deal they cut.
Well immediately Azara commissioned
him to producing "Horace"
and now you see Bodoni doing what he
wanted expressing himself as Bodoni
with his perfect balance, his black
ink on really good white paper,
his own recipe for his ink and he --
so from then on his work
just got better and better.
But there was another reason why
Bodoni wanted to stay in Parma.
What do you think that was?
Well you may be wondering
about romance in Bodoni's life.
He's by now 51 and if you scratch
around trying to find anything,
any whiff of scandal that -- you can
make guesses and many certainly have
but you know as a biography you've
got to hew to the facts so anyway
at the age of 51 he had begun
to suffer from the terrible gout
that pursued him for the rest
of his life and I think the idea
of a little sort of home
comfort seemed really good.
He had come to know this young
woman Margherita dall'Aglio
but she was unfortunately engaged
to somebody else but Bodoni was
so famous and so attractive
that she managed to get rid
of the other guy so
they got married.
The little chapel in which
they got married in Parma
but all was not entirely right
in this big year of 1791.
Bodoni had had metal
workers from San Pancrazio
which is a village outside Parma who
proved to be really useful working
with him two brothers and a nephew
and this is murky territory right?
This is murky territory.
He taught them how to cut punches
and so they were working alongside
him but they began to feel
that they were doing all this work
but they weren't getting
the acknowledgement
so there was a terrific
rift and they left
and started their own
printworks in San Pancrazio.
So I thought it would be interesting
for you to see their work compared
to Bodoni's and I think you
recognize the master, don't you?
Yeah. Round about the
same time Didot
in France the great
French printer got hold
of a copy of Bodoni's "Aeneid."
Now he may have got a
hold of a final copy
but Bodoni believed he had got
hold of an uncorrected proof
and it's possible that the
Amoretti brothers had been the ones
to get this uncorrected
proof to Paris.
As I say this is murky stuff.
It's not definitive.
Didot then produces his own "Aeneid"
and in the introduction he took
Bodoni to task and listed his typers
which I think is actually
just about as cruel a thing
as you can do to a competitor.
However, in time they learned
to admire each other greatly
and I'm not sure that
all was forgiven
but certainly matters improved.
I think Didot had to
back off a little bit
when Bodoni won a very prestigious
prize for printing in France
that no foreigner had ever one.
He was a workaholic and if
he wasn't actually designing
or printing he was cutting punches.
He cut thousands and
thousands of punches
but I think this is the
entrance of Senora Bodoni
that they would have
conversation on Friday afternoons.
They would gather their friends
together and enjoy themselves.
I don't see any wine but maybe
it's a little early in the day
but anyway it's a very
interesting image to read.
On the far left you have Bodoni
and next to him is Giusepe de Lama
who would go on to write
the main biography,
the biography that people
always use and quote from
but gets the birthday wrong
sorry, so they're clearly working
on something together maybe
Bodoni is telling him a bit
of his life's story.
Behind them is DALMASTRO, the
manservant for the Bodoni's.
In the center are three good
friends from Parma rather well-born.
One's a poet.
One's a count.
I forget what the third one is.
Top right is Zambiagi the
foreman of the printworks and then
down below [inaudible] slightly is
Signori Bodoni and Fernando Paer
who was a composer who
wrote the wedding march
for Napoleon's second wedding.
This is Rosaspina, Francesco
Rosaspina who was the one engraver
that Bodoni trusted to
do illustrations for him.
Bodoni very rarely
used illustrations
but when he did he
trusted Rosaspina.
[ Inaudible question ]
You know I can't think.
I'm not sure of the dates of,
I'm not sure of the dates sorry.
I think not, no when Fournier died
and the Didot's had
come in France, right.
This is Pietro Miliani who was
a paper maker from Fabriano,
where Fabriano still
produces really good paper.
He provided Bodoni
with fantastic paper.
The paper maker in Parma people were
jealous of Bodoni and if the kind
of [inaudible] he had at the
with the Duke at the court
and so he had to go
to -- can you see?
>> Yes.
>> Valerie Lester:
There's a seat over here.
Well, anyway.
Good I'm glad you can see so
Miliani was very loyal and kept
on producing the good stuff.
Recognize this chap?
Franklin wrote a fan letter to
Bodoni and it's very interesting.
He said, "Oh, congratulations
on your marvelous work
in such and such a work.
I really think it is
absolutely beautiful however,
had it been me I would
have done such and such."
So you know printers they
like a bit of rivalry.
And the Pope went to Paris to crown
Napoleon emperor and while he was
in Paris he met Marcel who
was the young librarian
at the Bibliotheca Imperial
and Marcel showed the Pope this
incredible volume he had just
produced which included 150
different types in many,
many exotic languages and the
Pope was deeply impressed.
On his way back to Rome after what
must have been a really discouraging
moment for him crowning Napoleon he
stopped in Parma, went to see Bodoni
and said, "Okay, can you
do better than this?"
Well could he?
Yeah. Of course he could.
One hundred fifty-five so he did it.
So this is from that work which is
an absolutely astonishing thing.
The Chinese lettering is interesting
in it because it was the only,
only type that he cut in wood.
Everything else he had cut in steel
but the Chinese he did in wood
and do you know why he
would have done that?
Do you know why?
Would it have been hard
to do that on the steel?
>> Stan Nelson: Well, it's
really easier in the wood.
>> Valerie Lester: Easier
in the wood, right, right.
Another wonderful moment for Bodoni
was when he became an Arcadian
which was a somewhat slightly
closed society of people
who were interested in keeping
the arts and writing alive
and so this is the big quite a
big piece of ephemera if you will,
printed in two colors and it's a
poem that Bodoni wrote in thanks
to the man who proposed
him to become an Arcadian.
This is in the Providence
Public Library
which has the Didot
Updike Collection
and a fabulous collection.
This is interesting.
I only somehow I had missed it.
I came to it right at the
end of writing the book
and I literally had
to say now hang on.
Hold the presses.
Stop, stop I need more time and
partly Parma which was not inclined
to think too highly of people who
are not actually born in Parma
and that remains to this day.
I mean Parma is very
pleased with itself.
Why would we go anywhere else
when Parma is so perfect?
Well, they finally produced a
gold medal in honor of Bodoni.
Remember the Duke?
Right, Bodoni is still
working for the Duke.
The Duke was pious
to a fare-thee-well,
a religious bigot actually and
but he was also a roisterer.
In the country I take honor he
has a hunting lodge and a chapel
so he could go off
roistering on Saturday evenings
and then go to chapel on Sunday.
Anyway he did love to eat and he
doesn't look so good, does he?
Anyway he died in 1802 and it
was a sudden and mysterious death
so in Italy when there is a sudden
and mysterious death
what do they figure out?
>> Poison.
>> Valerie Lester:
It was poison, right?
So that as a matter of fact
I've seen carved on a plaque
on the church where
he's buried it says
that he was [foreign
words] he was poisoned.
When the actual fact, I've seen
the doctor's records I think he had
something that is sort
of like a twisted gut.
Black bile they called it.
So anyway his having died
the Duchess became co-regent
with two others but within ten
days Napoleon had banished her.
There he is in the robes of the
King of Italy so she was banished
and he put in place this
man Moreau de St. Mery
as general administrator of Parma.
Now Bodoni, Bodoni didn't
care who he worked for as long
as he got commissions
and he got paid.
He went with the wind.
He was apolitical.
Bodoni thought of Bodoni.
He didn't think of particularly
of loyalty or of causes.
He thought about printing
the best books so he
and Moreau became really
good friends.
Then he printed his "Homer."
Took a long, long time and he had a
very, very slow editor but it came,
it is the most gorgeous
book I have ever seen.
It is I first saw it in
Saluzzo in Bodoni's hometown.
Bodoni had given copies of
all his books to Saluzzo.
So I was there in the
library and the library
and Giancarla Bertero
she came staggering
out of the trolley
three huge volumes.
It's very big and she took one
off and opened it on the table
at which I was working and I
thought I want to die here.
This is so beautiful.
I want to lie down
in this book and die.
It was so gorgeous and it
is in fact his favorite font
as we call it nowadays,
his favorite type.
He said that the Greek was
the one that he loved most.
Well maybe he got a lot of practice
with it certainly working
on this book.
So yeah, keeping up with
not exactly the Joneses
with Napoleon he gave a copy to
Napoleon and Napoleon was so pleased
with it that he made him
Chevalier of the Order of the Union
and gave him a pension for life.
Napoleon by now had gotten rid of
Josephine and he married, he was 39
and he married the 18 year-old
Marie Louise of Austria related
to the Duchess of Parma
but not related closely.
Napoleon wanted one thing
and she produced it, a son.
This drawing is perfectly charming.
I was in a museum called the
Glauco-Lombardi Museum in Parma
in the back offices talking
to the curator and it was
on her desk this little
image and I said,
"Could I take a photo of this?"
And she said, "Oh sure."
So you stumble on wonderful things
when you actually spend time
in a place so to celebrate
the birth of the king of Rome,
Napoleon's son Bodoni did another of
these fabulous presentation volumes
and unusually for his late
work he put a border around it
but as you can see it's a very
sort of austere grand border,
so it's a celebration of the
arrival of the King of Rome.
Still hanging in with the Napoleon
family he started working for Murat
who is I like to call
him the hot dresser.
Look at his green suede
boots for instance.
Anyway Murat was married
to Napoleon's sister
and Murat wanted his son to read
and learn the French classics
in books printed by Bodoni.
So he commissioned Bodoni
to print the French classics
and this I'm told was
Bodoni's favorite type of page
because he managed to get the words
"Boileau Despreaux" on one line.
He had to cut special
punches to do it but he did it
and he got those two
words on one line.
Takes all sorts of
pleasures different people.
Bodoni died of complications
from his gout and some kind
of nasty chest infection which
his wife called [inaudible]
but which I think must have been,
it was probably bronchitis
or pneumonia.
You can imagine the air he was
breathing in the printworks
for all those years that
he was working in Parma.
Part of him is buried in the
cathedral and part of him is
in his parish church in
this rather unpleasant way
of eviscerating people and
putting bits here and bits there
but that's the way it was done.
So he leaves behind Ghitta
his wife and she's formidable.
She helped him so much
while he was alive.
She, well she spoke French
and she learned English
so that they can correspond
with his English customers.
She did all his correspondence
for him.
She took care of him and he really
benefitted from this late marriage
of his and then the greatest
thing she did was to finish work
on his Manuale Tipografico
essentially his life's work.
It took her five years.
He had done, I mean it
was he had done the work
but it was not organized.
He had written an introduction but
she had to organize the whole thing.
She said herself in
her own introduction
that it was a labor she did
not know if she could entrust
to herself but could and she did.
So she in 1818 she
brought out and it's here.
It's two volumes there on the
middle of the table in the stand.
She brought it out and she
dedicated to the Duchess
of Parma Maria Luigia, Maria Luigia
was and now she's Maria Luigia
because she's Duchess of Parma.
Here's the largest type he did and
I think it's there you can see it.
The smallest type right at the
beginning he dedicates to Parma.
This one he dedicates to
Saluzzo his birthplace
so essentially he's
gone full circle.
The end of his great book is Saluzzo
the place he started his life.
Now you can't read this.
I know that but I have
it here for a reason.
This is another item in the
Providence Public Library.
People have always
said how many copy
of the great Manuale did he print?
Nobody knew.
Well nobody that I consulted knew.
This letter from Madam
Bodoni to a Mr. [Inaudible]
who is obviously a customer
said, "I have printed 250 copies
and I'm selling them for 125
francs each, no discounts."
She was very firm about that.
This is the plaque, the memorial
to him in the Parma Cathedral.
It's a very big and
very impressive plaque.
Below is a plaque to his
widow and on the left is this
which is rather nice to
know that the printers
of America have acknowledged
the great Bodoni.
I think you may have been
wondering what he looked like.
This is not Bodoni however, it
was said to be Bodoni for many,
many years until the clothing
historians got hold of it
and said he was too young in that
picture to be wearing that cravat.
All wrong, so here he is wearing the
same cravat as a mature man however,
if you look at those two pictures
side by side it could be Bodoni.
So many of the artists
were doing it from memory.
I don't know.
Anyway that's one of
those mysteries.
Very silly this one isn't it?
Very silly.
Now we have the modern ones which
just get sillier and sillier.
The one on the right isn't it funny?
I love this one.
This is my favorite.
There he is in his
working gear working hard
and I think that's probably a
good likeness, a nice new sketch.
You know somebody working
quickly and here this is
in his hometown this bust
of him and on it it says,
you may not be able to read it.
It says in English, "The Best."
Can I give you two more minutes?
Yes? I want to tell you a
little bit about the experience
of writing a biography of Bodoni.
So what work -- I had not
heard of Bodoni until going
to a dinner party eight, nine
years ago and I was my host
at this dinner party said you
know, he was very, very upset.
He'd just heard from a dealer
that he had a stolen book
that he had bought in all
innocence and he had to return it
to the library from
which it was stolen.
I at this point had
finished the first book.
I'd finished the translation and
I was looking for a new topic
and I thought oh stolen books.
That's interesting, hmm.
So I looked into this
particular theft.
I looked into book theft in
general and it's disgusting
so I thought I don't want
to do anymore with that
but in the meantime I'd
become interested in Bodoni
and I wanted to go to Italy.
I wanted to spend time in
Italy so I thought ooh,
this sounds like a good thing.
I knew practically
nothing about printing
and my Italian was [inaudible] so
I started going to Italian classes
and then the next big thing if
you want to write a biography
of Bodoni you start networking
and people put you in touch
with other people and you of
course you eat Italian food.
This is Sumner Stone who put
me in touch with James Mosley,
the great print historian and his
wife Jillian Riley who is an expert
on Italian cuisine
which he's written
"The Oxford Companion
to Italian Food."
They were so helpful
to me both of them.
My book is actually quite
reliable thanks to James Mosley
who is a very, very keen-eyed
as Stan will corroborate
with me a very keen-eyed editor.
And then you get to meet Mr. Nelson,
Mr. Stan Nelson and spend a couple
of days with him in West
Virginia watching him cut a punch.
It was a Caslon C as I
remember Stan, wasn't it?
Yeah, uh-huh and it took five
hours to cut that one letter
and Stan is fast so
you think about Bodoni
and the thousands of punches he cut.
I liken him to somebody who
is a nut about knitting.
His hands could not be still.
When he had a [inaudible]
he would cut another punch.
Okay so you go to Parma but
in I think this is in 2008
or maybe 2008 there are
very few Wi-Fi hot spots and
but there was one on the steps
of the 11th century
baptistery for some reason.
I never quite understood why and
I used to annoy the old priest
who came out with his brush to
sweep up the pigeon poo that was
on the steps and I was
always sitting there
and he would glare at me.
So if you're lucky you get to meet
handsome men and you get to converse
with really charming women and
you get, you have to get beyond
to the curator of the Bodoni Museum.
You have to make real nice,
nice with her and then you get
to meet her assistant who
turned out to be golden.
She did anything she could for me.
She's holding a fine
Bodoni volume here and she
and her boyfriend would take
me out at weekends to outings
to the countryside to see places
that Bodoni would have gone
to see the Duke's country
palace at Corlono.
We went to see hunting lodge and
the chapel that I mentioned before
and we would eat out
so it was lovely.
You know immediately I
had an Italian friend.
I did make from Jillian Riley
you remember the culinary expert,
the Italian she put me in touch with
a woman called Wallace [inaudible]
who is a writer who lives in Parma
married to an Italian professor.
She's American and she had a
writer's group which she invited me
to come and talk about
biography to them and they
because this is a small
society they sort of fell on me
because I was a newcomer and started
taking me out to other things
and I felt very at home in Parma.
I went a total of five
times to Parma.
So if you're lucky you'll get
to meet [foreign words] The
Exquisite Man, [foreign name]
who is probably the greatest
Bodoni scholar in Italy.
Well, there's a couple of
others that contest that
but is certainly one
of the top three.
And then Franco Maria Ricci
is an Italian publisher
and Bodoni collector and
collector of neoclassical art
and here we are looking for Bodoni
in one of his cabinets with part
of his collection above us.
If you're lucky like I was
you're there during carnival.
This picture is funny because the
figures at the bottom are the people
and the figures at the
top are the puppets.
[Laughter] And if you're
not so lucky you'll get
to be there during an earthquake
and I was alone in this room
when the world started
shaking and the windows rattled
and I thought all the books were
going to fall off the shelves
but they didn't fortunately
and we all ran outside.
It was quite dramatic.
I was there during two winters
when it snowed and snow in Parma is
because it's not a deeply cold place
although I must say I felt very cold
there sometimes, the snow will
melt quite quickly and then freeze
and it's a lot of cobblestones.
It is treacherous and because
I was spending every morning
from 9 'til 1 reading
18th century Italian
in spidery handwriting often written
on two sides of thin pages of paper
by one [inaudible] I was like
this so and I couldn't walk,
I couldn't get exercise so I
joined a gym called Fisi Labor
and Fisi Labor was set in a
palazzo so I was in this gym
with young Italian women a lot of
them with tattoos, a third of my age
and it was really challenging and
one day the teacher shouted at me
because I had slowed down a bit
and I said to her in Italian,
"I'm 70 years old" and everybody
in the room went ha-ha
and burst into cheers.
[Laughter] It was so funny.
So I was least getting my exercise.
So then if you're working on a
biography of Bodoni you have to go
to Rome because you think
you might find something
about the six years he
was in Rome and I managed
to get myself a little visiting
fellowship for five weeks
at the American Academy
which is very grand and
but in actual fact you can't
find anything about Bodoni there
because he was a lowly apprentice
and he did not leave a trace.
He did not.
There is no trace to follow.
So what I did while I was there
was I found his geography.
I found where he lived in the
Palazzo Valentini and I visited that
and I found you know 18 Propaganda
Fide which has now been moved
to the Vatican itself
so it's now a museum
where the people don't know
anything you know about the press.
It was very disappointing.
I was there during a flood on
the Tiber but this I did find
and this is the Vatican
printing press so this is
where the Propaganda is printing
its material nowadays very,
very hi-tech.
So when in Rome right get a haircut
like the hairdressers, right?
But avoid buying shoes like this.
>> Oh wow.
>> Valerie Lester: Can
you imagine walking
around on the cobblestones
like that?
And then if you go to Testaccio
there's a section there of streets
that are named for printers.
There's the Aldo Manuzio and
there's the via Benjamino Franklin
and there is of course via
Giovanni Battista Bodoni.
Giambattista you know
that's his full name
but it was always compressed
into Giambattista.
So by now you're tired aren't you?
And you see a wine shop and
so you think I'll just go in
and have a nice glass of wine.
[ Music playing ]
So that's it folks.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Dimunation: [Inaudible] I
didn't know about Volare but I have
to say that's a first
for the Rosenwald Room.
If you'd like we can take
a few minutes for questions
if you're not exhausted and then
afterwards we'll show you the
Tipografia and the Celebration Book.
When we do that we'll ask the
people on the benches to get
up push the benches and move
away so we can have you come by
and as I always say we'll be happy
to show you anything
you'd like to see.
And also before you if you find
yourself leaving there are two
bookmarks here advertising
events of the Museum of Women
in the Arts booklet arts
related that are coming up soon
but let's have questions
for our speaker if you will.
>> Valerie Lester: Don't
you want to go to Parma now?
It's lovely, lovely, really lovely.
Oh, silenced them with that last.
>> Mark Dimunation: Why
don't we clear the room.
We'll have some time you can
talk with Valerie afterwards
but let's thank her again.
That was really --
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.